[Music]
however in that this right thing which
conscience does is at the same time of
being for another it seems that a
disparity attaches to conscience the
duty which it fulfills is a specific
content it is true that this content is
the self of consciousness and so
consciousness is knowledge of itself
it's identity with itself but once
fulfilled set in the medium of being
this identity is no longer knowing no
longer this process of differentiation
in which it's differences are at the
same time immediately superseded on the
contrary in being this difference is
established as an enduring difference
and the action is a specific action not
identical with the element of everyone's
self consciousness and therefore not
necessarily acknowledged both sides the
conscience that acts and the universal
consciousness that acknowledges this
action is duty are equally free from the
specificity of this action on account of
this freedom their relationship in the
common medium of their connection is
really a relation of complete disparity
as the result of which the consciousness
which is explicitly aware of the action
finds itself in a state of complete
uncertainty about the spirit which does
the action and in certain of itself
the latter acts it gives being to a
specific content others hold to this
being as the spirits truth and are there
in certain of this spirit it is declared
there in what it holds to be duty but it
is free from any specific duty it is not
present at that point where others
imagined it actually to be and this very
medium of being and Duty is something
possessing intrinsic being count for it
only as a moment what therefore it
places before them it also displaces
again or rather has straightway
displaced and dissemble where it's
actual being is for it not this duty and
determinant character it is put forward
but the actuality which it has in the
absolute certainty of itself
here in paragraph 648 Hegel is now
leading us to the point where we can see
things start to unravel or if we want to
use the term that Miller is using a
disparity is going to emerge some sort
of disjunction and why is this important
well you know from two perspectives one
is as I pointed out in the previous
paragraphs as we know from so many times
before whenever there's something
immediate whenever there is a you know
something that has being in and for
itself whenever we've reached some sort
of you know reconciliation or what
appears to be the final step no it's
almost never the case with Hegel all
right things start to slide apart what
was a unity or to use a word that he's
using here and used a lot of the
previous paragraphs an identity AG like
height starts to separate out is still
being connected with itself not you know
into inert parts or pure abstract
moments but dynamically connected
moments and so that is what is going to
be happening now with conscience and to
jump ahead a little bit what we want to
keep in mind here is that what's
happening is happening you could say on
two sides and this is what I've put on
the board is coming from about midway
through the paragraph we have the acting
conscience and the universal
consciousness they are connected
together in this common medium which is
the action which assumes a sort of
status of being that we'll talk about in
a moment and the problematic is
happening on both sides it's happening
on the side of the individual who is
conscience decides for themselves what
their duties are acts according to those
gives them a certain specificity and up
until this point seem to have had all of
these things you know coming together
and you know we could finally see that
there's no universal like conch and norm
set uh you know over and above it ruling
it imperiously telling it you're not
doing the right thing instead it gets to
decide for itself it has autonomy it you
know this is a very important step it
seems on the other side we have the
universal consciousness which we've seen
now is not a like it's just an abstract
non human Universal it is the universal
of society of other people of other self
consciousnesses and neither of these are
going to actually get what they want
in this situation as we're sketching it
out here so let's start with Hegel's
vantage points this in that that's right
thing which conscience does is at the
same time a being for another that's
prefiguring here it is a being it seems
that a disparity attaches to conscience
the duty which it fulfills is a specific
content right and we've seen this
already we don't just have an abstract
sense of duty moral obligation we have
all sorts of more specific duties and we
also have a duty you could say a meta
duty of prioritizing and deciding
between these which we're going to give
the prominence to and say okay this Duty
over here this is the one that is really
the most stringent right now and that is
what acting conscience has been able to
do for itself so he says it's true that
this content is the self of
consciousness and so consciousness is
knowledge of itself its identity its
gleich height unity equivalence you know
however we want to frame that with
itself now then he goes on he says once
fulfilled set in the medium of being
this identity is no longer knowing no
longer this process of differentiation
or where's the differentiation what we
saw a bit of this different
two paragraphs before when we saw that
the action and the duty had three parts
to them content which is specific form
the form of morality and knowledge the
knowledge that conscience has of
something being its duty which it gets
to decide for itself all right so this
differentiation is is gone
right he says it's no longer this
process of differentiation and when it
in which its differences are at the same
time immediately superseded on the
contrary and being the difference is
established as an enduring difference
and the action is a specific action
let's pause on that for a moment what
are we saying here
so the acting conscience does something
action here is translated from the
German term handle right which which
means more than just a simple act taught
right but a way of behaving a set of
commitments that are that are visible in
the action and agency that the person is
is a locus of right so that becomes
specific and Ian as we've seen in
previous discussions going out into the
world the action in a way becomes you
know stripped away from or we could just
say goes on with its own inertia from
the act or and not in the sense of you
know moral responsibility you can still
say okay who broke the window that
jackass over there did throwing the ball
around well that's not that's an action
right and probably you know maybe they
intended to break the window maybe they
didn't who knows we don't have to worry
about that the ball certainly once it
leaves your hand it's got its own
impetus that's that's going to continue
you know if you've ever done something
like I remember we've the total side
note when my when my father died he left
behind a bunch of golf clubs because he
like playing golf as a matter of fact he
was such a great golfer he actually had
a hole in one and got a trophy for that
total side note and when we were kids
well we liked to hit the golf balls
around that were in the bag using his
clubs in our backyard and we were
fortunate and that we had a you know
quite big backyard and then there was
like an undeveloped wood line behind us
and all that now we happen to have a
luminance sighting house and if you know
anything about aluminum siding you know
that it doesn't do well with dents what
could make a dent golf balls will do
that I remember hitting a golf ball and
not meaning to hit it quite so hard and
it took off and it hit the house and I
was happy it didn't hit a window because
then I would have been in real trouble
but it hit the house and it sounded like
a rifle shot right kakaw and and and my
mom came house what the hell was it and
of course we played dumb oh I don't know
I don't know what's going on she saw
this dent in the siding and she was of
course very upset with us and we suppose
the end of golf for a little while now
you know what's the purpose in bringing
this up you know our actions are sort of
like that we do them with the
intentionality with the motivation with
the way in which we define them to
ourselves but then they're out there as
beings in the world they have zine they
are they exist
and they don't come with notes for
somebody to pick up the action and say
oh not only does this belong to this
person over here but oh I'm supposed to
read this action in a certain way I'm
supposed to view it as fulfilling this
Duty and not this duty over here that's
not available the the others get to
decide for themselves how to interpret
that action you don't get to keep
controlling it so he goes on and he says
the action is a specific action not
identical with the element of everyone's
self-consciousness and therefore not
necessarily
acknowledged this is sort of a
contradiction of what happened in the
previous two paragraphs is it not in the
last paragraph we saw that there is this
acknowledgment or recognition of the
action and the other person the other
self-consciousness by the universal
consciousness which is others and
perhaps we could say even a community of
others maybe something like the Koch in
kingdom of ends now Hegel's taking that
back and saying well it's not
necessarily acknowledged it could be
acknowledged
maybe somebody sees what you're doing
and you know infers the same
justification for it the same motivation
the same knowledge of duty or maybe they
look at what you're doing and they're
like what the hell are you doing well
you you idiot
what is this garbage that you've just
put out into the world than anything
like well you know let me explain to you
and then you explain and they're like
things are even worse now that you've
explained it a great example of this
that I just saw somebody discussing on
Twitter where you know conscience would
actually be doing something that we I
think most of us would see as bad but
the person is convinced that what
they're doing is not only ok but is
actually the right thing to do would be
telling a racist joke or a sexist joke
right they engage in this action why are
they doing it you know you could say
well they don't have a duty to do it
maybe some of them do they're like oh
man I've got this this funny thing I got
share with everybody in the workplace
and then they tell this joke and people
are like that is racist or you know
here's the tack that the person was
saying they say I don't understand the
joke can you explain it to me can you
and when you're doing that you're saying
can you make clear to me what's in your
mind as you're telling this thing what
are your assumptions
what are your standpoint and and you
know motivations in bringing this up and
then oftentimes the person will realize
oops I
I've screwed up now sometimes they'll
actually double down a little bit you
should find that as funny right and then
the people over here can be like screw
you buddy
you really screwed things up with this
you revealed yourself as being
conscience but a crappy conscience I'm
misformed conscience right and we could
go on and on with other examples about
how people don't have to interpret
things the same way that conscience
wants to so he says both sides the
conscience that acts and the universal
consciousness that acknowledges this
action as duty are equally free from the
specificity of this action so let's talk
about what it means to be free from the
specificity of this action the doer the
one who is is choosing the action as we
saw it you know in just two paragraphs
before has this autarky this
independence they in fact can bind and
loose that means that they can say okay
I'm changing my moral perspective I'm
changing my knowledge my practical
knowledge of what is right and good and
true and what I'm going to do in
accordance with that so they have a
certain independence and so does this
side over here it's not only the case
that you know just because you insist on
a certain interpretation of your action
nobody else has to buy it or to use
Hegel's term acknowledge it it's also
true that they can change their own
interpretation of it over time as well
right they're free as well I mean think
about this for a minute you want
recognition who do you want recognition
from you want recognition from robots
from beasts from slaves from people who
can't change their mind or do you want
recognition from actual human beings who
alone can give you the recognition their
honor cannon in German that you are in
fact desiring as a self consciousness so
it goes on and says both sides right so
I by the way there's a little
terminology or translation thing that I
want to talk about here in the German it
doesn't say the conscious
that acts and the universal
consciousness it just says the
conscience give this unison sorry that
is acting Honda right and then it has
the adjective universal now could it be
that it's actually talking about a
universal conscience as opposed to
consciousness I don't really think so so
I think Miller's translation here is on
point but it did want to single that out
as something to to you know mention so
he talks about them as having a a
relationship right in the common medium
of their connection and that this is
actually a relation of complete
disparity so this is one of those things
where there's a relationship there's a
connection there is a relation all these
terms are kind of thrown in there
together
and you can think of it as like
something where you're you're you think
you're on the same page you find out
that you're not you're stuck at the same
table with each other you can't get up
from the date you got to see it through
you got to ride it out except now the
date goes on forever
so this common medium of connection is
in fact the action which can be
interpreted in different ways and may be
acknowledged as duty or may not be
acknowledged as duty so he goes on and
he says on account of this freedom right
the result of which the consciousness
which is explicitly aware of the action
finds itself in a state of complete
uncertainty about the spirit which does
the action and in certain of itself now
who is the consciousness explicitly
aware of the action could be either side
so the spirits the mind the the you know
driving force that does the action and
it's certain of itself is the individual
in this case the one who in the previous
paragraphs we've seen has a certain kind
of independence autarky on the other
side we have another
sort of spirit I mean it's not as if
these are radically separated from each
other he says that the latter acts it
gives being to a specific content others
hold to this being the being of the
action as this spirits truth and are
there in certain of this spirits it has
declared therein what it holds to be
duty all right now there's certainty of
this spirit is it the same thing as the
the self certainty of this spirit that's
where we have the discordance the
possibility of difference of viewpoint
and interpretation so we go on and he
says that it is free from any specific
duty it is not present at that point
where others imagined it to actually to
be and that's very medium of being and
duty is something possessing intrinsic
being count for it only as a moment
what's free from any specific duty the
conscience over here that's acting now
this is important it does not present at
that point where others imagine it
actually to be so there's a certain kind
of arbitrariness or unreliability to
this acting conscience over here that
wants to pick whatever specific content
it's going to have and use and rely upon
and that is going to be a bit of a
problem as her shortly see so he says
what therefore it places before them it
also displaces again or rather has
straightway displaced and now he's gonna
use an important term dissembled do you
remember back in this section we had
decembe once first and so there's a
little bit of shiftiness going on here a
little bit of shadiness that we need to
pay attention to
he says for its actual being is for it
not this duty and determinate characters
put forward but the actuality which it
it which it has in the absolute
certainty of itself you might say it's
unreliability
others therefore do
whether this conscience is morally good
or evil or rather they not only cannot
know but they must also take it to be
evil for just as it is free from the
specificity of duty and from duty as
possessing an intrinsic being so
likewise are they with conscience places
before them they themselves know how to
displace or dissemble it is something
expressing only the self of another not
their own self not only do they know
themselves to be free from it but they
must dispose of it in their own
consciousness nullify it by judging and
explaining it in order to preserve their
own self
here in paragraph 649 we now see what
this disparity that the previous
paragraph really amounts to concretely
which is that somebody's got to be the
bad guy all right somebody if we want to
use the old song somebody's got to be
the bad man the sad man behind blue eyes
if you don't know that song you probably
want to Google holes lyrics because it's
a great little ditty so he says others
and who are these others these are the
universal conscience and consciousness
right which which the self consciousness
has to exist in relation to others do
not know whether this conscience is
morally good or evil good or you know or
musiah and so this is going to be really
important they don't know they don't
have knowledge and not just air chemists
they don't visit all right but this is
something vital to our interdependent
existence knowing what somebody else is
are they good are they evil are they a
mixture of the two it's also really
important to this issue of recognition
that recognition both of the the self by
the other and of one's conception of
duty and of one's actions what are we
going to see here by by a recognition
whatever recognition or acknowledgement
we thought we had that's gone away in
this paragraph how so he says that
others do not know whether this
conscience is morally good or evil
rather they not only cannot know but
they have to make an assumption and in
in German naman to take to assume they
must take it to be evil and he might say
well why the hell would they do that why
not just assume everybody's good and you
can say well this was not where he
this point in time but you might also
say that's not where you know
consciousness after all of this
development is at this point in time
either
there's also another aspect to this why
why they would think it's evil which
we'll see in just a moment but you know
we could pause of it why not just extend
the benefit of the doubt to everybody
does that work doesn't it does it
actually produce whatever it is that
we're after do we get recognition when
we extend the benefit of the doubt to
everybody we may do we may get some
until push comes to shove and then
suddenly we're on the other side of the
shop and they're on the side of the push
right so is this just self-protection
you know maybe in a certain way it is
but let's see what it says so he says
just as yet meaning the other is in this
case not the other the acting conscience
is free from the specificity of duty and
from Duty possessing and intrinsic being
so likewise are they so they know
themselves as being in a similar
condition they know themselves also as
similarly arbitrary fallible liable to
be driven by irrational desires by
self-centeredness by you know a
contentiousness with other
consciousnesses and their their you know
sort of shrewd in that way so he says
just as it's free from the specificity
of duty you know it can rearrange it and
from duty as possess any intrinsic being
what conscience places before them they
themselves know how to displace or
dissemble so they say that conscience is
placing something namely the act or the
action rather the honden and the duty
the flicked right and its conception
it's it's offering that to them they say
well that's actually not hinged Alan
it's not just putting it in front of me
innocently and saying here you go check
it out you know it's actually fair
Stellan its dissembling sore duplicity
to which we had an entire section
devoted in the development of morality
earlier on so this is really rearing its
head the fact that others could be
deceiving us about their intentions and
about their actions and about what they
think to be their duties you know this
is the case all the time right I would
be remiss if I didn't sell you this
crappy car and take your money and set
you up for financing in this way I
wouldn't be doing my duty to not just as
a Salesman to put food on the table for
my 14 kids you know and pay my mortgage
and all that but also for you the
customer when you hear stuff like that I
like yeah come on be yes that that's not
really duty that's that's decembe once
they know that they're just as liable to
do that themselves they may have
memories of having deceived people in
the past now what do they see going on
here what are they reading into it he
says that what conscience is doing is
something expressing only the self of
another not their own self so it's it's
it's something that you know may be
genuine but it's really from this
person's perspective not their
perspective it's good to sell a car
sometimes in the abstract but it's not
good for me to buy your crappy car
that's going to break as soon as I get
it off a lot and even if it doesn't
immediately start depreciating alright
cars are a terrible investment so the
others are perfectly aware of this and
he says that not only do they know
themselves to be free from it but they
must dispose of it in their own
consciousness and he says they nullify
it they literally make it nothing by
judging and explaining it in order to
preserve their own self so there's a
projection that's going on here it could
be that this conscience over here really
isn't bad isn't evil is actually good is
actually noble but there
being brought under an interpretation
where they are going to be interpreted
as evil precisely because there's this
possibility of deception and they the
others know it because they themselves
would do it if they were in that place
and indeed have been in that place
themselves so this is going to be now
the downhill slide we've got conscience
the individual labelled as evil
you